jose albert came to the country from the
dominican republic and 30 years later he
was doing what he came to do which is
working he's 61 years old and he had
friday night a week ago at midnight he
was working in a convenience store in
harlem
when a violent criminal walked in in a
dispute over a bag of potato chips his
girlfriend was trying to walk off with
assaulted the much older alba threw him
to the ground grabbed him by the neck
ultimately alba stabbed the guy clear
self-defense the video's online if you
haven't seen it you should watch it's
very upsetting so then the thug's
girlfriend shows up and starts stabbing
alba
not in self-defense out of rage which is
not allowed
but the soros-backed d.a in new york
alvin bragg charged alva with murder but
did not charge the girlfriend who
stabbed alba
so after public outcry alba's bail was
lowered but he's still in home
confinement he's still facing murder
charges
the video that we just got from the new
york post makes it very clear that alba
did everything he could to avoid a
confrontation with this criminal watch
this
what's up with you i don't want a
problem
[Music]
i don't want a problem with you
the guy threw the old man down then
grabbed him by the neck now he's facing
murder charges vina fasella has served
in congress he's now the borough
president of staten island probably the
best borough spoken out in defense of
alba beautiful thanks so much for coming
on tonight um this
are we missing
details it seems like an incredibly
straightforward example of self-defense
by a virtuous guy against a thug
you're absolutely right you know this is
wrong on so many levels uh those who
know the trend in new york city know
that crime was on the rise bodegas which
this guy worked at uh robbed almost once
a day they're in very confined spaces
they're vulnerable they tend to be in
very often low income areas
and
we also know that violent criminals have
been let go they get arrested they're
back on the street and then along comes
this poor guy just earning a living
is threatened assaulted
trying to defend himself and if there's
anything uh real and right in this
country is the right to defend yourself
for your property and rather than arrest
the woman who stabbed them this poor guy
is facing 15 to 25 years in jail so we
did just a few days ago in staten island
some folks may not know new york city is
comprised of five boroughs five
different counties each borough has its
own district attorney what we said on
staten island is that if you get
attacked if you're assaulted you have
the right to defend yourself and while
they may put you in jail in manhattan
staten island you'll get a medal and for
some reason we have this alternative
universe that's being created where the
victim has become the criminal and the
criminals become the victim and what we
want to say is let's get our city back
let this guy go and let's get the
violent criminals off the streets that's
our message
well i mean it's pretty obvious that
members of politically favored groups
are just not going to be punished no
matter what and and this alba was not a
member of that group so he is being
punished but how can you not if you're
the d.a
how can you not charge the girlfriend
who also stabbed somebody and can't even
claim self-defense that's totally
revealing i think
it's it seems to be just absurd to
insane um you know and anybody with a
half an ounce of common sense looking at
this video has to feel for this guy and
as i said rather than charge the people
who initiated this threatened him
assaulted him are now looking to put him
behind bars for up to 25 years
something's got to give you know nasa is
releasing its
web telescope
today or tomorrow they're going to
release images of new york city into
foreign land in so many pockets of this
uh community that's a great city it's a
vibrant city but too often we've we've
seated the seat streets over to the
criminals yeah it wouldn't be hard to
fix it just do the obvious reward good
behavior punish bad behavior it's not
hard beat a facility i appreciate your
bravery thank you thank you
thank you tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight